Lucy doesn't want to be identified
because she is scared the 25 year old
was two months pregnant when she was
raped last October she says a man
wearing a police uniform came into her
bedroom while she was sleeping she says
her husband sometimes asks why she
didn't fight back I'm gonna why he would
he asked me where my husband was I said
I didn't know he called me a liar
then he said my husband was one of the
people organizing with protests and that
I was hiding him he forced me to undress
and then he raped me human rights
lawyers say police aren't doing enough
to investigate a series of allegations
of rape and sexual abuse against their
officers the attacks happen during
months of protests in several parts of
the country following the result of the
presidential election last May at least
one police officer and a civilian were
killed in some of the violent protests
at least 17 women one was actually
sexually assaulted and the eight that
were sexually abused this includes fun
during breast groping or kind of stuff
then we have again eight that a set of
being sexually I mean
molested through virus police say the
allegations are still being investigated
and no arrests have been made
we even indicated to Minoans that with
this for criminal investigations all
things being equal will be through in
two weeks however all things were not
eco because some of the investigators I
mean some of the complainants the
survivors we are not forthcoming when
they were needed by our investigators to
get more from them however that issue
has been sorted out investigations are
going on smoothly and we are very much
sure that any time from now will have
the criminal investigation report out
there masu brave illage with some of the
women live so some of the worst violence
following the election the police
station was destroyed during an
anti-government protest late last year
since then it's been abandoned people
here say they don't trust the police and
they don't want them to return the
Constitutional Court recently announced
the result to relay Peter Metallica
because of what judges said were
widespread irregularities
Metallica disputes that and is appealing
to the Supreme Court to overturn the
verdict there's an uneasy calm in Malawi
but opposition supporters and human
rights activist are threatening more
protests if things don't go their way
Jarro Matassa al Jazeera will soon be
Malawi